un moment qui nous a tous émus on a vu
philippe etchebest pleurer mais là il a
fleuri regardez il était extrêmement
touchée voilà elodie a raconté à
philippe etchebest son histoire
personnelle et les dures épreuves
qu'elle a traversées
ce qui a beaucoup touché philippe et ça
c'est très mignon franchement j'ai adoré
vous avez adoré non mais c'est vrai j'ai
vu j'adore cette émission donc six mois
oui sinon on analyse médian mécontents à
paris vont demander si j'ai aimé après
vous donner mon année alors verra dit
alors je la fais maintenant je trouve
que dodo ce que tu as dit pardon a perdu
un petit peu là la raison en embrassant
patrick le tdi amour idiot ça s'appelle
un format donc quand tu regarde devant
et ça change tout le temps oui c'est
reviennent sur la même chose quand tu
regardes motus sabah des boules c'est la
vraie vie c'est cela prévient alors si
vous nous rejoignez de façon je vous le
diront il dit toute la vérité
elles sont de ce soir est ça fera une
place pour deux donc il y en a une femme
et c'est justement ça était scellé de
belles mères en boîte
phaneuf tout cela se regarde et regarde
pas perdu mais un premier bébé j'ai fait
que je m'arrête quinze jours quand j'ai
pu recommencer travaillé quinze jours
après celle à qui s'est cassé sa jambe
et deuxième opération quinze jours après
comment ça s'est passé ce jour là
justement que s'il faut opérer et ben
c'est moi qui gérait le restaurant tout
temps et j'étais enceinte enceintes
amplifiées sur le cristal est ni à 5
mois et 2 jours donc je faisais puis 155
g et 30 cm ça avait pu bien du monde et
on était à dix
judith tu sais je me suis marié j'ai mis
mon tablier contaminé je le rendrai mon
dernier saut bien c'est là où je te
laisserais
[Musique]
[ __ ] les confidences d'elodie me met
une claque
l'amour qui les unit est indéniablement
leurs forces dans la vie et au travail
[Applaudissements]
je fais où je fonçais il alimente
d'avoir foncé comme ça des avoirs
compétition et s'est agacé avant donc il
a doublement regrettait d'avoir été si
brutal au départ
[Musique]
truc s'est cassé la gueule il prend son
mêlant merci là franchement isabelle et
mathieu aussi je vais venir au secours
de la gare délire est totalement c'était
une émission totalement impudique
c'était devenu vulgaire où elle à tizi
ouzou et la cuisine franchement vous
avez des torrents de là vous avez de
chevet ofit qui profitent du malheur de
saison le conditionner les aides qui
fait pas venir nous c'est une émission
ils ont tous franchement la caricature
mans s'est loupé la cuisine l'eau chaude
et ben haim
j'aimerais y venaient le voir tomber la
mjva illico les jaguars une animalerie
ça m'étonne de toi toi qui d'habitude
dit et je suis le zorro d'aidé du du dge
cet hommage au jus la zorro humains
masques et ils devront faire de même et
carita une émission on est dans le
véridique dans la véracité il ya 76 %
des établissements pour lesquels ils
sont venus en est qui perdure oui c'est
un pur jours si seulement sur 34 ont
fermé il ya un os difficilement coty et
quand il se passionne en demandant est
ce que vous pouvez les chants d'hier
mais mon petit appartement où tu es pris
à défaut tu dis je vous parle
travaillons sur calme jean michel jarre
s'il en quoi la sincérité tels que le
vieillard soient impunis est ce que
c'est un public ton quand étage notes le
rendement dans la malle fatwa à l'autre
ça émouvant vous mêlez part à toi sa
mère la non et ça on a trouvé ça ne
m'est pas fait toi ça d'accord pourquoi
ne mêlez pas rien qu'on a là là là bas
tout là dedans alors pas alors s'il vous
plaît elles méritent autre chose que
vous oui c'est vrai je vous confirme
donc gérer mais ridicule quand on est
sincère